TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is the Developer Show.
We're here at Google I/O 2016.
And over the next
several weeks, we're
going to be putting out some
episodes on specific topics
discussed here at
I/O. But for now, this
is what it felt like to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're here at the ground
floor of Google I/O 2016.
I'm here with Dion Almaer.
Dion, how are you doing?
DION ALMAER: I'm
doing really well.
Yourself?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
doing fantastic.
DION ALMAER: It's go time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We
are T minus two days.
DION ALMAER: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're going
to sneak around and take
a look at the I/O grounds
right before it gets done.
So you get a
behind-the-scenes look
at how I/O 2016 came together.
DION ALMAER: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, now this
is a completely different
micro environment.
I think there's going
to be a lot of Android
and some Firebase talks in here.
DION ALMAER: Yeah, even
some improv comedy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is
that in here too?
OK.
Let's go find some people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, so Chet Haase
is here to tell us
about the cool stuff
that's getting set up.
Now is there
anything that you're
going to announce
that you don't want
to tell our audience right now?
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
We're going to need to bleep out
the following phrase-- [BLEEP]
and this next one too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Android.
CHET HAASE: [BLEEP] not yet.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
What do you hope for this
I/O outside of your sessions?
CHET HAASE: Really good
developer engagement.
Is that the phrase
you were looking for?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Tell me about the dinosaur.
DION ALMAER: Yeah, so there's
this fun little feature
of Chrome where
if you're offline,
a little dinosaur comes
out, and there's actually
a game that's in there.
And you start hitting the
space bar and it jumps around.
And this year, we want
to kill this dinosaur.
We want to kill him.
We always think
of the offline use
case of like, oh, what if
we make it so when Timothy's
on a plane, it still works?
But in reality, with cell
networks and the like,
it's going up and
down all the time.
So you don't want to
just be in that second
where you've got poor
network capability, all of it
stops responding.
Now you can take
ownership of that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well let's
play a game of foosball.
I think we're going to
explore this in some detail
again later too.
But the cool thing
is it's got NFC.
And you can just tap
your Android phone
and it keeps score for you.
DION ALMAER: So what would the
score be right now if we'd--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You'd
be winning decisively.
DION ALMAER: I'm British,
so you know, table football
is in my blood.
And thanks for hanging out, man.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, Dion,
thanks for hanging out
with me as well.
It was really fun to explore
behind the scenes at Google I/O
2016 with you.
DION ALMAER: I hope the
developers have a great time
this year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
think that they will.
ANNOUNCER: Welcome
to Google I/O.
SPEAKER 1: Today we are
announcing the Google
Assistant.
SPEAKER 2: Google Home.
SPEAKER 3: Allo.
SPEAKER 4: Daydream.
SPEAKER 5: Android Wear 2.0.
SPEAKER 6: The next
generation of Firebase.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, so Chu Ki,
you were in the audience during
the Google I/O 2016 keynote.
I have a few questions for you.
What are you most excited
about that was announced today?
CHU KI CHAN: It was
kind of towards the end
when they did the
Android instant apps.
Meaning that, if you want to
send somebody something that
is better in an app
experience, but the person
doesn't have the
app installed, he
doesn't have to suffer with
just using the web interface.
He can want just the part
of the app that he needs,
and no need to install anything.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
CHU KI CHAN: That was amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
CHU KI CHAN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
what is it that you're
most excited to work on as soon
as you get back to your machine
at home?
YOHAN TOTTING: I
think the first thing
that I want to-- I want to build
with a lot of new cool things I
saw, like in Firebase.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Firebase.
YOHAN TOTTING: Because
web developer and also
mobile developer, the
biggest challenge for us
is actually talking
to the backer.
Right?
If you focus on
the web, you need
to learn also about how
you can build the API.
But, using the
Firebase, I think you
can forget to think about that.
You can just, using
the API, throw the data
into the Firebase,
and you can just
focus in your front
[INAUDIBLE] app.
So.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Absolutely.
YOHAN TOTTING: Yeah,
it's a good thing for us.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What are some
of the things at Google I/O
that you're the
most excited about?
LON HYLAN-CHO: Oh, definitely
the multi window support.
And N. Like, that's
really exciting.
I think, especially when
you're watching television,
because I write
television-related apps.
Like, that's something that most
people do while multi-tasking.
They don't just stare at
the television, right?
They're doing other things.
So having the multi
window support
so that you could have
TV on one side of it,
and then like be
checking your email
or whatever else on the
other side without having
to leave the app.
That's really cool.
TAMARA WASHINGTON: Home.
To the person who's left her
phone in her refrigerator
before, Home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In the fridge?
TAMARA WASHINGTON:
I actually have--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's inventive.
TAMARA WASHINGTON:
Well no, I've put it
down to get something
out and closed
the door didn't realize it.
And, you know.
Cause you're always looking for
your phone for either a recipe
or what time am I
supposed to be here?
Or when am I supposed
to be doing this?
If I can just yell out to
something, that's fantastic.
Cause I'm always leaving my
phone somewhere in the house.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What are some of
the other things at the keynote
that you're excited
to play with soon?
TAMARA WASHINGTON: I'm
in material design.
I went to some of the
sessions they had on it.
It looked really interesting.
Because coming from a
developer's background,
understanding what design
terms and what design
is needed, those type of things.
So yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
We're here at the
After Hours at Google I/O 2016.
I'm here with Dion and Ben.
Hello, gentleman.
DION ALMAER: How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's going well.
How are you?
DION ALMAER: I went from
going from on stage giving
a talk to having
to just be up there
with this speechless
improv comedy night.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And how was that?
DION ALMAER: It was fantastic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So one of my
favorite things about Google,
and I think you gentlemen
share this as well,
is that work and fun are
not mutually exclusive.
And that comes out
in I/O as well.
So we spent all day learning
all these new technical concepts
and API's, and at night, let's
have a little bit of fun.
DION ALMAER: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
shall we do that?
DION ALMAER: Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
I think we should start
with the underwater disco.
What do you think?
DION ALMAER: That
sounds like a good idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right this way.
DION ALMAER: Let's go then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-By the way, do
not play foosball
with any of [INAUDIBLE]
They destroyed that tonight.
10-0.
It's like-- it was like that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that's
what it felt like to be here.
Thanks for joining us on the
Developer Show for Google I/O
2016.
And stay tuned over
the next several weeks
as we bring you more content
from what was discussed here
at I/O. And don't forget to
like, subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.